we can't leave our mothers here when the
war started we were here if we leave
then who will bring peace to our land I
[Music]
didn't with the foolish and Stillman
Allison we grew up in the Luba Mountains
the war
targeted us in our homes we have no
other place where else would we go we
have to stay here peace will find us
here my name is or dénia Jamal of drama
when my mother sent me to school I
didn't understand why it was important
but over time I learned that education
could be more important than the army
[Music]
one time the planes came when I was on
my way to school we ran into the foxhole
for shelter a shopkeeper standing nearby
refused to enter we called out to him as
the bombs fell his body was separated
from his legs by the shrapnel and his
head fell inside the foxhole we climbed
out covered in blood we thought it was
ours
we didn't answer I arrived late on
Monday the principal wanted to punish me
I didn't tell anyone what happened
got nothing to baldly my
if people were really educated we
wouldn't fight with weapons we would use
our brains and communicate better with
pen and paper